はい日本のみなさんこんにちはーん
肇社長です照明変えたはいいんですけど
難しいんですよ取る位置が立ってこう
この位置がいいなと思ったんですけど
なんかライトが節水あり後ろにあるから凍ったら僕が暗く見える理由のグロック楽なん
ですかちょっと
を回りに比べてとりあえず今日は
とのかなって
動か所業であります
大人ザリコ柚子胡椒味ですソイ
ゆずこそうですうつの大人の
なぜです
ここに wiiu ず譲って書いてあるんですよ
すごいんじゃく銭高いですね10ずといいですがこう
逆になってる譲りたくないよ美味しさ
すごい曲線高いいっ
9名
こういう中にですね
ケーズの本サーズ行ったことないんですけど
楽しいって聞いたんですよね
いただきます
あんまり国内文献とスッキリしてて食べやすいですね
けどちょっと大きな大きなとか香りそうなんで
ちょっと
気を付けたと方がいいと思います
me
腹ちょっとかない
後から来る後からちょっと
などからからいい
何が
この章せっかく正面明るくしたのに
ねこう使いこなせてない自分がいて
イラストレーションが溜まってるんで
ちょっとまた色々な場所で動画を撮ってみますねー
だってこうしたらもうのすぐ座ったら顔ず映らないですねこの場所は
微妙かな
なあ皆の衆が高
何を指の
ねっ
お供に
持ってくれるはずだぞじゃあどっ
ni